it's so wonderful to catch up with you
because
first of all have you settled in to your
house
you you built a house is that isn't that
crazy
honestly i pinch myself every time i
wake up in my own house
i never in a million years so i'd have
my own house ever um it's so cool it's
so nice at my own space
i built my house but next door my mom
and dad also built their own house
so technically i have moved out but like
i can go over to my mum and dad's house
and they can do my washing and they can
iron me
wait your parents are next door yeah
damn girlfriends in the house
oh my god your mom's gonna be watching
no this is the thing
there's been there's been some ground
rules here when they're allowed around
they're not allowed just to come around
you know they they need to text me i
need at least a day like notice before
they come over because i can't have
anyone just walking through my door
there's no way man your mom's gonna be
walking in any time she wants
i've i know she's about banned her for
now
and you designed this house i understand
the concept on minecraft is that right
yeah yeah i i've always been obsessed
with minecraft when i was little
and uh i designed the house on there
when i like a couple years ago just for
fun like if i ever
you know design my own house i'd love to
have it like this and i tried
architects and now it's kind of come
true that's really cool
that's so cool i'm building a house
right now too so i know how you're
feeling
that's so cool that's so it's it's hard
it's hard it's a lot of patience
yeah a lot of patience but you'll you'll
be amazing it'll be great oh i can't
wait did you finally get your blinds
because you were using your boxers as
your eye mask
yeah no i actually i still haven't got
any blinds
so i actually did upgrade from boxes and
i did buy
an eye mask um but i haven't used it
i've
i actually don't mind waking up to the
sun you know it
wake up a lot easier but i do need to
get blinds that's one thing i need to
get actually
reminded me yeah that's the next thing
to get uh the fact is now you have a new
house you have
new music out right now a summer anthem
one day two nights this
i love the beat i love the song it hypes
me up it is brilliant
i mean how did you hook up with kylie
minogue i mean did you call her like
how does that even happen she's a legend
okay so this is a really really funny
story okay
i actually did for some reason in the
press release
people think that kylie minogue wrote
this song with me but
she didn't she didn't no she didn't so
basically she
signed to the same label as i am but in
the press release
it kind of almost no it almost says that
basically can't even not quote my song
so in all my interviews that i'm doing
everyone's like how did you get kylie
minogue
i didn't but we you know we can roll
with it i wish that kylo ren was a part
of the song
but unfortunately she's not but she's
trying to i recently signed the new uh
a new record deal and she's she's under
the same record label so that's probably
where
the mix-up is that's good have you
talked to her have you ever
had a conversation with her no i but
my someone who works with me a producer
he's also worked with her as well and
apparently she said that i'm i'm a good
singer so that's kind of cool
oh that is pretty cool unfortunately no
no song together but maybe one day
because she is a legend crossing my
fingers for that and
the song is so beautifully done even the
lyrics i mean is it a moment from your
life and what inspired it or what
inspired or who
inspired it but no so during the first
lockdown okay
out we kind of after after the first
lockdown was like a little period
where everyone could go out again
especially in the uk and
everyone's emotions were pretty
heightened you know no one had seen each
other and i wanted to touch each other
and uh i met this person and on a night
out and she was uh she was really cool
and i ended up spending the next couple
days with her and it was like
one night and then the next day i spent
with her and then went out again the
next night
and it was a bit of like a whirlwind of
an experience and she was really really
cool
and i didn't end up leaving her house
for like a month and then
there was another lockdown happened and
then yeah now we're just friends but
it was one night well one day and then
two two nights and that was like the mad
kind of movie
it was like it was really cool um does
she know the songs about her
nah she
[Laughter]
just watching your tick tongue videos
and i love the way no they're great
they're great and i love the way you're
promoting this song
and and also there was a challenge where
you put on a tuxedo like
it is you're yeah how how has the
response been from fans
yeah really they do you know what i
i feel like everyone needed a bit of a
dance song because i was
in the studio originally i wanted to do
like a slow balladly kind of like chill
song but i feel like
everyone's been stuck inside recently
everyone's been in like in their fields
listening to emotional music and i'm
like we need something that goes a
little bit harder you know
we need a dance song so my fans love it
and it's being played on the radio in
the uk which is really cool so like
i'll be walking down the street and i
can hear it playing in someone's car and
that's the coolest and they're vibing at
least it's
such a cool feeling it never gets old
yeah you yeah i think there's a tick
tock video where you respond to the fact
it's on radio for the first time
and how you felt about it it's crazy
it's i don't know i feel like when
when your song has been played on a
radio or even being played on a playlist
in other people's cars or at parties
like that's such a cool feeling because
people actually like dancing to your
songs you know and that's what that's
that's why i do it to make other people
like
happy you know you're making people feel
good i love that and this video makes
you feel good
the wall of the walls you have the heel
seed
you have the matthew mcconaughey moment
you got it all like all of it
where did the concept come from uh wolf
of wall street is my favorite
uh favorite movie of all time and i love
leonardo dicaprio
and i just wanted to wear a suit i just
wanted an excuse to
dress up the 80s and kind of walk around
an office feel like a boss
you know so i was like i want to do that
and we did it and it and it worked out
and it was so much fun and
the director was amazing and yeah i
thought was really cool
don't guess me because honestly if that
is a i'll remember that
that's made my week that is that you
just said i'm gonna tell
everyone that you said that i look a bit
like leo yeah
i will take that he needs to see this
video
i hope he does this video he needs to
see the video i'd love for him to see
the video
i mean unlikely but yeah you never know
you never know you guys can be in a
video together i mean is this a now
do you have an interest in acting i love
acting i don't know how good i am acting
but i do love it
so maybe one day i could do it i just i
just think it's so cool to be like a
movie star or a tv star i think that's
so cool
yeah put it out there in the universe it
could happen right now you never know
you never know and the fact is this is
going to be our summer
anthem this song is absolutely amazing
but i need to know what's on your summer
playlist
wow that is a really really really good
question um anything olivia rodriguez
okay love olivia you want to collaborate
with her right
i would love to collaborate with her
she's amazing um
some of the new i think reckless is the
new madison beer song that's really
really good
um there's a lot of dance music in the
uk right now
that's yeah so any anything dance dance
kind of related i like listening to i
love khalid
tate mccray yeah yeah really eilish oh
i mean so many people loud
lots of american artists i like
listening to american eyes
they're cool you also like country music
i don't mind about country music i
listen to country music all day all day
yeah and you met one of our uh canadian
guys
shawn mendes i understand that you're a
bit star struck by
meeting him have you connected with him
recently
not recently but he is just he's a godly
human he's like a
he's just a god he's when i met him i
was like wow that's
sean mendes and he's like he's muscly
he's like
good looking he can sing he's nice he's
canadian
like i mean he's just got it all really
and
uh yeah he was really nice and we did it
we did exchange numbers he was very kind
to me
um we spoke a little bit but i haven't
spoke to him in a while but
i hope he's well i think he's releasing
new music soon as well which is really
exciting so that's cool
yeah you know you've gone through a lot
and all of us have
i mean the silver lining for you as you
built this house or making music i mean
what have you learned about yourself
through this process and
what are you looking forward to once
everything is kind of back to normal
i think i've learned to it's okay to not
it's okay to not be busy like i always
felt like
i need to be busy i need to be doing
stuff i need to be progressing in life
and i feel like putting that pressure on
yourself is really really hard
so i feel like having that kind of like
the last year or so
to kind of sit and sometimes do nothing
and that's not a bad thing
and i think that's what everyone needs
to learn um
so yeah i think i just learned to be a
bit more patient with myself this year
and also just go with the flow
like who knows what's gonna happen you
just gotta
live life and see what happens because
who knows really
so yes yeah congratulations on
everything
so wonderful chatting with you so let me
show you
you